子供のころのトラウマといったら小学校のとき
鉄を自分で削って作った手裏剣をこうやって本当の家がやつを機にこうやってやる練習
をしてたら
威徳に刺さってお母さんにめちゃくちゃ怒られたことです
弾み社長です今日僕の家にある人がきますよってです
なるほど受けで4つが家に来るんですけどもまぁ
ラッキーでしかけていきましたもう恒例になってるんでそろそろ寝ちゅうやつをやって
ももう食べて本人もにゃんにやってもらっちゃっと思うんでちょっと今回はひ at さ
せる感じでいきましょうはいこちらゴルフボールですね今回このゴルフボールを使って
なによっているかといいますと
部分人のベランダから外に向かってこれボールは1個ずつ買って落としていって変な
ピンポイントの場所を作るんですよ
で変なピンポイントの場所にそのゴルフボールを高いところから落として入れたら勝つ
というまったくもって右目がゲームをします頑張ってポットを置いといてすごいに書い
たさんがめっちゃ高いこところから超えて落としてアハハッハイスたら
甲冑というもう何を競うかも全く意味不明なゲームをやりますそれを使って何をしよう
かというと4つと僕
交互にやっていくわけじゃないですかを女性とね
そりゃそういうのも住めたら落とすとき誰かに当たるとダメだでお互いその場所を確認
するために落とさない人は下におりますよっていうの番の時に落としますでをと
タイミングで僕ちょっと友達の一人仕掛人で車を獣医させたんでその車に五竜ボールが
落ちて当たっちゃってフル間に穴が開くドッキリをしようと思います
というわけで今回準備したのがこちらこれわかりますステッカーなんですけどもグラフ
とかに貼るとゴルフボールがめり込んでるみたいになるんですよ
よくコツなど見つけたよ早いこれでね完全にゴルフボールがね春と出てるみたいになり
ますゴリぼれほぼ一緒みたいなもんですねほぼ同じ4つが落とします下にあった車の
フロントガラスがバレちゃいます
いやーと行かずやっていこうと思いますちょっと友達と打ち合わせしてちゃんと書いて
しまう
周りに人が立っただめだから4つというのが交互にさあ車が来てないことだして前だっ
ておりますとってね
でもすでにこれ貼ってあるからガラスが割れる音をだしてますんでね指示出したかった
んだ
バッチですか認めかもいい
[音楽]
うーんですよ戯れるぞヤシが入っていうよってさん
はい君はもってますか a と思ってますよ奇遇ですね多くも持っています
まさか
[音楽]
で強い歯違うが違うあっ必要ですねどっちが持ってるかっていうのはちょっと
解決しようと思います若さでのシーンの方ところっていうのはな
決めるとかばショット何度も決めるわけまあそうですね確かにこれでボールやっをお
やああああああああっ
明け暑さなんでそれかといいますと上から貼って落としてみ米欧として最近に入れた人
が勝ちというゲームをしようと思いますなるほど
オールいますねこの意味不明な企画に彼が放った一言はこれであるポール今ですね取っ
てよっておりごと買ってルアーを決めたれたブラジャーさあ
だけに言うとマーカーしてください北矢ケ部ですよこれ昔この部活焼くだけ
クラピカスプーナーだからこう落とすというなるほどではやっていきましょう
あえんげんっていこうと思いますよっちまずは折だぞ
ターン
に入っ
4月
わーい
ミティ e ですよ
入った
ねマジで欲しくねー
これたぶんいけるは体毛イースタン a 次屋
僕らファンです
水2まあ5
風子いますえっ
ほい全然だよ不変風船ぱウェア
g crew
ん
ねっ
3ませーのはい
生男所とっこれでもやばくだけ
時間のものですって言われるんですねいけるいける俺はいける
ディスカー
ok ですよん
2うわぁファイヤ
はぁ
一の
システム全て光
ww
えっ
アウディ s 7
ほいでこれさっすぐに
ん
すー
分
ええええええ
andere
今回は4
俺が悪い国家やこれ
頑張って登り結構分かりやすく無い上から見たらそうでもないですよ
本当にっ
teame
dea
car
うううううっ
一心でもびっくりしたいやびっくりしますよね見てないですから
阿蘇1回見てイースかっつって確認したかったんですこれ本当にあってるかなーっ
ば行っちゃったらビッグビビったえーるああっビビるでしょそりゃどうなんかわかん
ないですからね多分金蹴りで見るとまずは分かるんだけどああただみるとまずではかん
だかがわからないです
取り上げて今回の時
には4つが車のフロントガラスを割る
ドッキリでしたはい今思ったらそんな簡単に言われないんですよね
なんとかです